memory is everything
without it we are blind
without it we lead the plate of our
world to chance
[Music]
today we're learning english with
another lesson from the harry potter
legacy are you ready this movie will
help us learn more about young
dumbledore played by jude law as well as
his relationship with grindelwald and
how this affects the war between them
but before we start each week we release
lessons to help intermediate and
advanced learners like you improve your
english in a fun and dynamic way without
getting lost without missing the jokes
and without needing subtitles so if
you're new here make sure that you join
our community of over 5 million learners
by hitting the subscribe button and the
bell down below right now
i'm sorry to disturb you thomas but i've
just received troubling news tell me
what is it it's grindelwald
her time is closed my brothers and
sisters our wall with the michaels
begins
today
the world as we know it is coming undone
if we're to defeat him
you'll have to trust me mr kowalski we
need you said it wanted out on that one
out
you do know i'm a witch right
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous visit in a
century
who wouldn't like our chances
[Music]
no one can know everything
not even you
what are you doing is madness
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
after save the world are we
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
i swivel but delicately
i'm swiveling out you suffering
[Music]
i'm sorry to disturb you promise
when you disturb someone you interrupt
what the person is doing
i'm sorry to disturb you
quite a while
but i've just received troubling news
when something is troubling it makes you
feel worried and tense
i have very troubling news
duffman is undergoing hip replacement
surgery
the world as we know it is coming under
to come undone is a colloquial phrase
that means to disintegrate or to break
into parts or pieces the word undone is
a good example of word formation in
practice we call it word formation when
we have a word that has its original
meaning changed by a prefix or suffix
for example the root word here is done
by adding the prefix an the word takes
on an opposite or negative meaning
undone is the same as not done not
performed or not finished
will leaves with us
and you can take jack
done
undone
done
if we're to defeat him
you'll have to trust me
the structure of the sentence is really
nice the subject is to do something here
are some examples you are to do the
dishes before going to bed
she is to report to her boss once a week
we are to deliver this package before
february
you can use this structure to tell
someone what to do it has a similar
meaning to the phrase to be supposed to
do something check out these examples
you are to do the dishes before going to
bed you are supposed to do the dishes
before going to bed the difference here
is that the first sentence sounds more
adamant in other words it sounds more
like an order
the second sentence on the other hand
simply states what is expected of
someone said i wanted out and i went out
this phrase is spoken really fast and
with elements of connected speech in it
check it out the d at the end of sid is
pronounced with the flap t and is joined
with the vowel i
so it sounds like
said i
the verb wanted is in the past tense
notice that the letter t is dropped to
be here wanted
the d for wanted is pronounced with the
flap t and joined with the word out
want it out
the t in out is pronounced with the stop
consonant
the linking word and is pronounced an
and then it's joined with i
as in
and i
finally the t in want is dropped so we
hear the n being connected with the word
out
one out
notice that the t in out is again
pronounced as a stop consonant ou
when we put it all together we have i
said i wanted out and i went out
listen again said it wasn't out and i
went out
what are you doing is madness
another way to say this phrase is what
you're doing is crazy madness is the
noun form of mad which means the state
or condition of being mad if you call
someone mad you're calling that person
crazy
do you think i should have told them
dumbledore and the others i mean are you
mad no harry even in the wizarding world
hearing voices isn't a good sign
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
this is a phrasal verb notice that some
phrasal verbs allow you to place the
preposition at the end burn down is one
of those phrasal verbs
so you can say
i'll burn down their world or i'll burn
their world down
to burn something down means to destroy
it especially by fire
okay rule five safety first i.e don't
burn the building down
okay
swivel but delicately
which one of these images best
represents the verb to swivel
to swivel means to turn around a central
point to face in another direction
imagine someone needs your attention
somebody say my name chris swivel
what is jerry you told me to say your
name and you did a great job superstar
someone else say something you look like
a freak swivel
when learning a new language it can be a
huge challenge trying to figure out
which words and expressions are
important and which ones you may never
need without the guidance of a good
teacher you could waste a lot of time
learning the wrong ones but don't worry
because with our fluent with friends
course you can learn words and
expressions that native speakers
actually use every day plus you'll have
tons of fun doing it with the tv series
friends which various academic studies
have proven is the best show to learn
english
in this course you will also learn how
native speakers reduce cut and connect
sounds which is the secret to
understanding us no matter how fast we
speak you can try it now for free
without three-part masterclass
so what are you waiting for simply click
up here or down in the description box
below to sign up now
[Music]
what is this place
the room we require if by tea time all
of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
mr kowalski my pleasure
we really intend to turn you back on
your own kind
[Music]
because you said we could reshape the
world even if we make mistakes
we can't try to make things right
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna need some help
[Music]
that's nothing you can do to stop me
[Music]
[Music]
very dangerous it's very powerful i've
gotten wrong hands you know
mess you up where did you get it
the guy for christmas
can i keep this
[Music]
if by tea time all of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
british people are known for their love
of drinking tea
in many places in england tea time is
usually around 5 p.m
however it's important to mention that
tea time is not just about drinking tea
but simply having one more meal during
the day
we shall have supper early they'll be
ridiculous
it's six o'clock would you tell the
kitchens we'll eat in 45 minutes but
it's tea time
do you really intend to turn your back
on your own kind
when you intend to do something you have
plans or intentions to do it depending
on your first language the word can
easily be confused with pretend for
example brazilian learners tend to
confuse pretend with intent remember to
pretend means to fake being someone
you're not for example actors pretend to
be different people in the movies they
make some children pretend to be
superheroes when they play with each
other
we really intend to turn you back on
your own kind
which word is related to turning your
back on someone to fight to save to
abandon
when you turn your back on someone you
abandon that person and refuse to help
them this is a fixed phrase
okay why not now you're going to turn
your back on us
we really intend to turn you back on
your own kind your own kind can be
understood as people who are like you or
who come from the same place as you
rounding who up john
hey damn john we hunted our own kind
logan
we're gonna need some help this is a
very common reduction but it's worth
mentioning it here anyway many times the
words going to are reduced to ghana in
speech this helps you speak more
smoothly
listen again
we're going to need to know in which
options do you see a similar reduction
used to went to
one two got to
[Music]
just like ghana one two often becomes
wanna and got to often becomes gotha
it's very powerful i've gotten wrong
hands you know
mess you up
to mess someone up is a phrasal verb
that means to cause someone to suffer
emotional and mental problems in the u.s
this is a slang phrase that means to hit
someone repeatedly so that they are
badly hurt however if you tell someone
that they might mess it up you think
that they won't do something well
so if i mess this up there's nothing
else for dessert
you're not gonna mess it up
wow monica i love that you really have
faith in me thank you
i'm sorry to disturb you thomas but i've
just received troubling news tell me
what is it it's grindelwald
her time is closed my brothers and
sisters oh whoa with the marcos the
kings
today
the world as we know it is coming undone
to come undone means
to be uninvited to disintegrate or to
break into parts or pieces to come to
existence
[Music]
if we're to defeat him
you'll have to trust me mr kowalski we
need you said i wanted out on that one
out
you do know i'm a witch right
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous visit in the
century
who wouldn't like our chances
[Music]
no one can know everything
not even you
what you're doing is madness
with or without you i'll burn down their
world have to save the world are we
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
what do we call this movement
[Music]
swivel but delicately
i'm swiveling right you're settling
what is this place
the room we require if by tea time all
of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
mr kowalski my pleasure
we really intend to turn you back on
your own kind
[Music]
because you said we could reshape the
world even if we make mistakes
we can't try to make things right
[Music]
we're gonna need some help
[Music]
that's nothing you can do to stop me
[Music]
very dangerous it's very powerful
forgotten wrong hands you know
mess you up to mess someone up means to
cause someone to suffer emotional and
mental problems
to hit someone repeatedly so that they
are badly hurt
both
[Music]
where did you get it
the guy for christmas
can i keep this
if you enjoyed today's lesson then i
definitely recommend that you check out
this one next let's watch
what is it
what's what that pulling the carriage
nothing's pulling the carriage harry
it's pulling itself like always
[Music]
you're not going mad
i can see them too
you're just as sane as i am